[موسيقى
] الشعور الذي ينتابني
عندما أرى هذه الطيور تطير إنه
شعور جيد تمامًا لأنه
يمكنك في الواقع رؤية كل الجهد
والعمل الجاد الذي بذلته في
الصقور في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لقد بدأ الأمر منذ حوالي
ألفي ونصف عام
تقليد قديم
للصيد بشكل أساسي ولكن ما أفعله
ليس ما يفعله سكانك المحليون ، ما أفعله
هو في الأساس التحكم في الطيور ، فنحن نستخدم
هذه الطيور
لمطاردة جميع الغربان والحمام ، لذلك
لدينا مناشفنا
التي نذهب إليها  ناطحات السحاب في المباني العالية في المدينة
والمناطق السكنية حتى
المطارات التي
درستها بالفعل في جنوب إفريقيا
للعمل مع الحيوانات
، ثم وقعت في حب العمل
مع الطيور الجارحة ،
فأنت تشكل رابطة بين هذه الطيور لأنني
أراها من الشباب في
الواقع لتنمو  لذلك من المهم جدًا
بالنسبة لي الاعتناء بها والتأكد من
صحتها ، فنحن نستخدم الصقور والصقور عادةً
،
لذا فإن سبب استخدامي للطيور المختلفة هو أن
لكل طائر وظيفة مختلفة لصقرك
الذي لدي هنا اسمه هو توم الذي أستخدمه
لمناطق متخصصة أكثر تركيزًا ،
حسنًا ، لقد انتهينا الآن من
الصقر والآن سنطير بالصقر والآن سنستخدم
الصوان هنا صوان ذكر
وسنستخدمه
الآن للطيران أعلى قليلاً و  تغطية
المزيد من الأرض ،
أحب ما أفعله منذ أن انتقلت إلى
دبي منذ حوالي 8 سنوات
الآن أنا أعمل فقط مع الطيور ، لذلك من
الجيد جدًا أن
تحب ما تفعله وأقوم
به في الهواء الطلق كل يوم